so I stolen your seat and here it is
here it is yeah what was your experience
of writing it like I think it was sort
of like a marathon in the sense of it's
not like pure joy every step of the way
go and I was approaching it with a lot
of seriousness and a lot of heaviness I
was like oh my God it's a book in those
moments I had to sort of other people
had to remind me that actually it's just
a book amazing this is a bit of a
different episode because I am in the
guest seat and I'm being interviewed by
Dr Judy Smith who's a clinical
psychologist and the author of the best
setting book why has nobody told me this
before and so this is Julie interviewing
me about the book how did it all begin
so to me feel good productivity became
this sort of like holistic philosophy
productivity is actually more about
being creative and thinking broader than
it is about just like efficiently
cranking out more and more widgets so I
can eat chocolate all the way through
when writing absolutely yeah we're going
to be talking about the principles of
Feelgood productivity we're going to be
talking about the energized principle
the unblog principle the sustain
principle we talk about the different
ways that we can incorporate feeling
good into more of our work so that we
can ultimately do more of what matters
to us in a way that's enjoyable and
sustainable and feels meaningful
preferably without burning out I think
success without recognizing the fact
that the journey is ultimately what
matters tends to be pretty Hollow for
most people and so from fairly early on
I was always in the mindset of like okay
the journey is actually more important
than the destination improve your
productivity and and be the best that
you can be but also kind of enjoy the
ride yeah a bit better absolutely cuz
what's the point of being productive if
the ride is miserable exactly I love it
oh by the way in case you have not yet
heard my book is about to come out it's
called Feelgood productivity how to do
more what matters to you and it's a book
that I've been working on for the last 3
years now it's being published at the
end of December 2023 but pre-orders are
actually available and I know people
don't like pre-ordering the book but if
you do pre-order the book and you email
me your receipt you will get completely
free access to a live exclusive event
that I'm hosting in the first weekend of
January of 2024 and this is a live
online Workshop all about annual
planning goal setting and reflection and
so I'm going to be facilitating a group
with hopefully hundreds of people from
all around the world and we're going to
be going through how to figure out what
to do with our life and how to turn that
into goals for the year and how to build
systems and how to be consistent with
stuff and how to make sure that we are
enjoying the journey along the way that
is purely exclusively available for
people who pre-order the book as a thank
you for our little community so if you
want to check it out you can check out
the book you can maybe consider
pre-ordering it the link will be down in
the video description so I've stolen
your seat and here it is here it is yeah
the final piece that's the one how does
it feel looking at it in the Flash if it
feels pretty good like I sort of we've
we've just done the interview with you
on this which has come out like many
months ago uh or was done many months
ago depending on when people listening
to this and kind of seeing it alongside
your book makes it feel like real and
I'm like this is clearly a real book
that's like doing really well and I'm
like okay we can they can sit by side by
they sit side by side on the same table
Good Vibes even though this one is
actually fake cuz we are recording this
um at a time where we actually don't
have the complete printed version so we
have a random book inside this one step
too far by Lisa Gardner this is just
like holding up holding up the cover um
but by the time people are watching or
listening to this it will be it will be
available and so that's feels it feels
kind of scary I don't know if you had
that when you when you release a book
yeah hugely I mean do
you at this point you know it's sort of
is going to LEAP out into the world what
what's the feelings that there's a bit
of scariness bit of sort of fear yeah
what what else is there yeah it's a
feeling
of a feeling of anticipation because
it's like there's been a lot of buildup
and like the last three years of my life
have been like it's been a project
that's always been always been there and
I I've I felt this like overwhelming
sense of guilt when I'm doing other
things to be like oh I should be working
on the book but like there's all this
stuff happening in the business and all
this stuff that I want to do so now that
it's finally done it feels like a big
relief but also like I don't know part
of me is like um you know there's that
that Zen Buddhism Parable or something
which is that like you know when an
Archer kind of does does does everything
they can and then and then when they
release they stop thinking about it
because it's like at that point it's out
of your hands it's kind of like you know
it's out of my hands at this point
people really like it the arrows in the
sky people will either like it or they
won't yeah and yeah like either way I
will still continue to learn stuff make
videos and write yeah whatever happens
yeah so it Almost Doesn't Really Matter
What have exactly and you've kind of you
put Lots in there haven't you and I
guess you've done so much like you said
it's been a long time coming you've done
loads of research all the way along to
kind of put loads in there yeah but I
wonder if I I think lots of people
myself included will be interested in
almost the beginning of the story so why
you landed on working on productivity
and how how that sort of came about for
you because that's
been sort of Fascination for you through
the YouTube thing and how did it all
begin yeah so I've been I've been
obsessed with productivity for quite a
while um I found that when I was at when
I was at University going through
medical school and trying to build my
first business on the side I realized
that I had to find ways to become more
prod Ive and ways to work harder and
work smarter and learn how to study
efficiently and stuff so that I could
have the time to do the things that I
wanted to do but then and so that worked
throughout University but then when I
started working full-time as a doctor um
that was like a step up in terms of like
oh you know I didn't think I had free
time at University now I really don't
have free time cuz like at University
even even in medical school going into
the hospital is kind of optional you
wake up in the morning and you're like I
don't know if I feel like going in today
um or yeah I'll go in for a few hours
hours I'll leave at lunchtime and then
do my own like self-study when you have
a job that you know that's just that's
unfeasible like you have to show up and
so all of a sudden like 10 to 12 hours
of every single day were just being
blocked up by work and I was trying to
grow the YouTube channel on the side and
I had a lots of periods of where I felt
pretty overwhelmed and pretty stressed
by the demands of work plus the demands
of the YouTube channel and so that was
when I was like okay I need to change my
approach to productivity that's where
this idea of sort of feeling good like
positive emotions and stuff landed cuz I
I didn't really want to be in a position
where every day felt like a grind cuz I
was in that mode for a while I was like
okay what if being productive and like
doing the things I wanted to do didn't
have to come at the expense of my like
physical and mental health what if I
actually could feel good while also
being productive and then I went on this
whole like research rabbit hole and
found that actually feeling good is one
of the keys to productivity and actually
the more positive emotion we feel in our
work the more productive we become but
also the more energy we have to give to
the other important things in our life
and so to me Feelgood productivity
became this sort of like holistic
philosophy that I you know I I I use
every day when I whenever I'm doing
something and it feels bad or I feel
blocked or I feel like kind of the the
negative emotions getting in the way I I
sort of remind myself that okay no there
are ways to make any situation feel
better and the way ways to experience
the positive emotion and everything and
it just means that I can float through
life well float through life I it means
I can go through life feeling better
about the work that I'm doing while also
being pretty pretty effective at the
work and and and it's interesting I
guess because you have have both types
of experience so you know when you were
working as a doctor in hospital where
when you're dealing with people who are
really unwell or really highly stressful
situations it must be really hard to
find the pleasure in that kind of work
in comparison to you know a YouTube life
and and where you can kind of choose
your hours a bit more or do things that
you're interested in so were there quite
different challenges yeah so this is the
thing so when I first started started
working I found it very like stressful
and sort of these high high stress
situations and most of the doctors
around me also had that approach where
it was like there was this sense of like
uh kind of tension and stress in the air
but not everyone was like that and I had
a few seniors who I really looked up to
who were just like they were really good
doctors but they were they were also
happy they were like had a smile on
their face they would crack jokes and it
kind of helped me realize that actually
there is another way
like approaching work as if it was it
was really stressful was actually a
choice that I was making
and so I did also make a concerted
effort in my day job to enjoy the
day-to-day a little bit more and kind of
modeling the doctors that I'd seen who
would have Smiles on their face and
stuff
started it sounds weird but approaching
it with more lightness and ease almost
as if I was playing a game kind of um
and it's not playing a game in the sense
of you know people's lives are at stake
but there was a line from gry's Anatomy
that I I often thought about which is
when uh Derek Shepard the neurosurgeon
when he starts his operation he says he
puts a music on and he says to it here
and he says to his team it's a beautiful
day to save lives let's have some fun
and obviously you know that's a
fictional fictional drama but there's
something about that that even when
you're doing neurosurgery even when it's
just like like life and death is in the
balance it can still be a beautiful day
to save lives you can still have fun
along the way and so much of that I
found is a choice that we make ourselves
rather than a rather than a thing that's
foed upon us by the environment yeah and
I guess with any job however difficult
or kind of emotionally taxing is there's
always something to be grateful for or
something to find in it that we feel
thankful for or find even the slightest
pleasure in I guess yeah I think I think
gratitude is a is a really major part of
this um the other one is you know this
is the first chapter of the book is the
idea of approach approaching work in the
spirit of play where yes even even when
the thing is really stressful you can
still choose to approach it in the
spirit of play and you know there's so
many stories of Nobel Prize winners who
found you know the key to their
productivity and the key to their
creativity was kind of treating it with
a little less seriousness yeah and
heaviness that we tend to approach work
with even when it's heavy and serious
like working in medicine or being a
therapist and things just choosing to
approach it with a little bit more
lightness and ease yeah so I tried to
kind of I I tried to do that when I was
in the day job and especially now
running this business and having a team
and stuff again a lot of people I a lot
of business I know is a lot of business
owners I know are pretty stressed
because of the demands of running a
business and managing payroll and having
all these people dependent on you but at
the same time it's it's a bit of a game
approaching it in the spirit of play
yeah yeah that the the idea that that
Joy is the most kind of important factor
when it comes to being
productive is
that at the core of this whole thing so
it's a sort of that's where you start
yeah sort of um so the the scientific
basis for this is a theory called the
broaden and build Theory um so there's
this researcher in the early 2000 called
Barbara Frederickson who kind of coined
this Theory to basically explain the
fact that when we experience positive
emotions it boosts our performance in
almost everything it boosts our
creativity and it lowers our stress and
you know her Theory very Loosely is like
if you imagine back in caveman days
because we're still operating with
caveman brains back in the caveman days
if if life is good if you're feeling
positive emotions it means means that
you're not in danger of being eaten by a
lion the group is surviving life is good
and so you're more open to exploring and
you go out into your environment and you
forage for new stuff and you see you see
if you can make some new alliances
whereas when you experience negative
emotion like fear or stress or anxiety
it's like uhoh my life's in danger a
lion could be around the corner and you
your entire being contracts and you go
tunnel vision for survival and when
you're in that survival mode it's a very
high stress State because the body is
literally kind of trying to survive
whereas when you're in that kind of
broaden stage it's like broad it
broadens your repertoire of things that
you can do and it builds like resources
like alliances and like creativity and
things like that um and so that was like
a thing that I came across in my
research um where I felt that that was
really the key and so if we can
experience positive emotions joy in our
work it just has all of these benefits
it generates more energy for us and
often for a lot of us time isn't
necessarily the limiting factor energy
is the limiting factor but you know
when you when you experience joy and
positivity in your work you end up with
Boundless Energy and you as a side
effect you become more productive in
your work but then outside of work you
also have way more energy to give to the
other important things in your life yeah
and it's interesting because you there's
um uh sort of Lit Literature around that
idea but in young children so sort of
that you know if you have a a young
toddler for example and they they are in
a kind of threat mode and they'll feel
anxious and they'll go to their mother
to feel safe and once they you know they
get that reassurance and they feel safe
or they receive a positive emotion or
experience a positive emotion from an
interaction with that mother they'll
then go out and take more risks and and
dive into whatever the situation is and
play with other children all they needed
was to feel safe and to have a sort of
positive emotion and then they're ready
to go out again and and exper so does it
sort of help with risk taking and trying
new things or creativity is all kind of
Linked UP absolutely no I think that's a
great that's a great example with the
with the kids I wish i' thought to put
that in the book cuz that's that's like
absolutely
perfect we'll do some edit to the book
um no it's like yeah there's just so
much evidence so there there was a the
first study that really tested this I
think it was from from like the 1980s
there's this thing called uh I think
it's called the matchbox puzzle Al
what's to that effect where you give you
know they get people in a in a lab and
they give them like a matchbox and a
candle and like some like thumb tacks
those are things that you yeah pins put
stuff in the wall
and you know the challenge is find a way
to get the candle to light the candle
but without any any wax dripping onto
the floor or something to that effect
and this is like a classic test of
creativity because people who are more
creative in that moment will discover
the solution where people who are less
creative won't and they found that if
you prime people with positive emotions
like giving them a m teaser or something
just before they do the thing they're
like way more likely to solve the puzzle
through creativity amazing and so it was
that study that was in I think in the
1980s that sort of helped spawn this
wave of research into how even for
adults positive emotions do make us more
creative and increasingly in the world
that we live in where most people
watching or listening to this are
probably knowledge workers or students
of some sort productivity is actually
more about being creative and thinking
broader than it is about just like
efficiently cranking out more and more
widgets so I can eat chocolate all the
way through when writing absolutely yeah
that's one going to help me with our
creativity absolutely yeah more the more
we feel good the more productive we are
that's a great piece of res Arch um how
about the sort of you know the industry
so far because I feel like you know I've
followed your work for a long time and
as someone who sort of steered away from
the more like sort of hustle culture
productivity where you're just you know
you just get up at 5:00 and you just you
know don't go to sleep or you you know
you grind and grind and grind because
that's what we do and it's all for you
know this thing called
success your content from the very
beginning was different that wasn't it
so it was it was always this way that
you always had that sort of recognition
of life is a bit more than that just
succeeding for succeeding sake we need
to look a bit deeper into that so what's
your take on the kind of the hustle
culture and the sort of productivity
industry generally yeah that's a great
question so I think
I sometimes when people come across my
YouTube channel and they don't watch the
videos they'll kind of badge me as like
a toxic productivity kind of guy because
it's like oh they'll see videos and how
to manage your time and how to be more
effective and stuff and to me that's
always been like like to me productivity
is about using using our time
intentionally effectively and
sustainably like working towards the
things that truly matter to us and part
of the reason like we we almost never
use the word success in the book because
I don't really like the word the word
success because for a lot of people
success is tied up in kind of
traditional Prestige or what other
people will think yeah and the
experiences that I had working as a
doctor like from the first year of
medical school onwards anytime I'd meet
a doctor and would get on with them I
would ask them hey you know how much are
you enjoying your job like if you won
the lottery would you still keep doing
it and stuff and so often there were
these these like really high Achievers
who had gone through high school and
medical school and everything and gotten
to this success who sort of felt like uh
I kind of like I wish I'd had more of a
life I had all these Hobbies when I was
younger and then I let them all go
because work got in the way and so I
think success without recognizing the
fact that the journey is ultimately what
matters tends to be pretty Hollow for
most people um and so from fairly early
on I was always in the mindset of like
okay the journey is actually more
important than the destination yes when
your book hits the best seller list as
yours does you feel like that flash of
like yeah but if the process of getting
there was like a grind and didn't feel
good and you didn't take care of your
physical and mental health and maintain
your relationships along the way a lot
of people say that like the success is
not worth the pain if it means your life
becomes out of balance yeah so I'm I've
always been about just trying to trying
to make sure life stays in Balance
trying to enjoy the journey as well as
aim towards some sort of destination and
what was the journey like to you know
create this book and write it what was
your experience of writing it like was
it painful it yeah I think it was sort
of like a marathon in the sense of it's
not like pure joy every step of the way
but like it's a fun experience overall
I'm glad I did it overall and I think
I've taken a lot of lessons away from
writing this book that I will then apply
to future books to make the process of
writing feel feel more good because even
though like I I found myself in a lot of
instances where I was writing about
Feelgood productivity and I wasn't
applying the same principles to the
process of writing the book and
sometimes it would take like my editor
or my you know or agent or the or my
writing coach to be like hey it's you
know it sounds like you know at this
point you could use the strategy that
you mentioned in Chapter 2 of like
sincere rather than serious like often I
was I was approaching it with a lot of
seriousness and a lot of heaviness I was
like oh my God it's a book A book is a
big deal with a big b and a Big D and
it's like oh my God like all of the
Imposter syndrome got in the way all of
the fears around why would anyone care
what I have to say what the hell do I
know and in those moments I had to sort
of other people had to remind me that
actually it's just a book who cares like
you know we can approach it with
sincerity rather than seriousness and
approach it in the spirit of play rather
than the spirit of like grind and
hustle and so now that I've done it once
even even though I literally write and
research about this stuff I still have
to remind myself because it's just so
easy for the mind to pop into serious
heavy mode especially when working on
something that you feel is like you know
I'm I'm comfortable making YouTube
videos and podcasts I'm a lot less
comfortable writing a book it's the
first time I did it and so there was all
these emotions that I had to deal with
along the way and and it's interesting
because you know there is that sense of
when you're writing a book that you feel
that need to sort of um do something
extra special with language or you know
dress it up to sort of Warrant a book
and and yet all the people that follow
you and love your content I think well
from my experience I love it because of
how you communicate already and how down
to earth it is and how you know you'll
read all these complex books and make it
really easy to understand and and lay it
out on the table as it is and um which
is a a skill and a talent in itself
isn't it sort of being able to translate
that for people in a way that's engaging
and entertaining yeah so were you able
to kind of just give it your voice in
the end and speak as if you're just we
just chatting across the table Yeah I
think in the end uh through throughout
throughout the Journey of of writing the
book there were periods where it was
very voicy in my voice and there other
periods where especially when I was
leaning on Research cuz I I wanted it to
be science backed I didn't just want it
to be a book from my own personal
experience yeah and so especially when
trying to talk about the science I found
myself kind of in academic writing mode
you know this study done by blah blah
blah and blah blah blah it's sort of
like how you'd write an academic essay
but not how you'd write an engaging book
and so those bits were the ones that we
did a lot of editing on to be like okay
how do we tell the story of This
research study in a more engaging way
how do we lead with some sort of story
um but I think overall it's it's in a
place now where I was re Pro proof
reading it the other day and I was like
huh this is actually not bad this is
this is reasonable because I guess you
would know when you're writing a book
you're so in it that when you take a
month away and you read it and you read
it back you're like okay yeah yeah this
seems legit like that's a pretty good
response isn't it when that tendency is
probably to be really critical because
it's your own work it's a it's a
promising kind of thought process to
have when you're reading it back yeah
how how was your kind of process of
writing so did you sort of lock yourself
away and be alone for periods of time or
you know integrate kind of team members
and chat and explore ideas how did it
how did it work yeah so there was a lot
of different methods I I tried like
every method Under the Sun over the last
three years cuz I was like there must be
a there must be a method um the thing
the one thing that got me to actually
bang out the first draft because as you
know the first draft is the hardest part
was it was I think about two years ago
two years ago or last year at some point
I can't remember uh 2021 maybe I know at
some point we did like a team Retreat to
this big Airbnb in Wales and the whole
team was there there was like like loads
of bedrooms swimming pool everything
like that and my job was every single
day I need to write one chapter and so
over the course of like six days I wrote
six chapters and it was just like the
only thing I had to do that that entire
day and the team was around doing their
stuff and like you know it would be 10:
p.m. and i''d be just finishing off the
chapter and then going down to the
swimming pool to like hang out with the
team and throw like the ball around and
stuff amazing so there was something
about just having that one thing to do
that day yeah that really helped kind of
move the needle but also with the first
draft I think a big part of it was
recognizing that it's going to be fast
it's going to be bad it's going to be
wrong but that's fine it's it's just a
first draft nice and it's like with
YouTube videos I now know and as as
you'll know with with the short form
content as well it feels really it feels
like it's an absolute [__] show when
you're filming the thing because of all
the different takes and all the the
pauses and the stops and the internal
feelings and the all that stuff but then
when it gets edited the end result is oh
you know it's actually actually pretty
reasonable because they've taken like 60
Minutes of footage turned it into a
12-minute video with like nice
background music some good animations
and now I've experienced that process
when it comes to the book I'll be a lot
less concerned about the crappiness of a
first draft for future ones because I
know the magic of editing and actually a
lot of the value has come from the
editing so it's just getting something
on the paper to then edit rather than
having to be perfect as it's typed out
that situation and I think when I was in
the mood of trying to get it perfect as
I was typing it out that was again that
seriousness of like and that seriousness
it felt like a real blocker that made it
less fun that also made me like write
fewer words whereas when I sort of went
back a bit more lightness a bit more
ease in the spirit of play sort of
having like Lord of the Rings music in
the background while I'm just sort of
typing away and thinking yep no this
sucks but that's fine we'll just keep
going we'll just keep going and at the
end like some of it was was fairly
reasonable even from the first draft and
and if you got swimming pool there to
get into that the kind of good driver to
to just get the words down right so you
can go and in that case it was like cool
like I want I want to go play with a
with a gang and I need to finish this
chapter first and are the chapters quite
short how's it kind of set out are the
chapters kind of short and easy to
consume or is it is a prog do you sort
of progress through it and yeah how does
it work um so we've got nine chapters uh
so three parts of the book part one is
energize part two is unblock and part
three is sustain which are like the
three different segments of elements of
feel good productivity and each each
chapter has three like top level
strategies and each strategy has like
two experiments that we're calling it
like practical ways that people can
apply the insights into their life and
so overall we've got nine chapters 27
strategies and 54 actionable experiments
which feels like a lot
um but in the first draft it was about
twice as many um in that each chapter
had about 18 action points until the
editor was like guys I I know you want
to throw the kitchen sink at this
because like you want to add more value
but like come on no one's going to read
like it becomes overwhelming if people
have 18 action points in every single
chapter yeah so we then did loads of
cutting got rid of anything that was
that we didn't think okay this is really
good and we were left with 54 is still
quite a lot but across the nine chapters
across the different elements of
productivity it feels a little bit a
little bit more reasonable okay so you
kind of you can sort of progress through
and do the little action points and
sounds like a good idea that it's kind
of trimmed down so because it's
difficult isn't it to work through you
know a book and um but I'm really
interested in the three sections you
said energize unblock sustain and so we
kind of talked a little bit about the
energize and and the energy is really
that main kind of driver yeah what's the
unblock yeah okay so the the energ
section is BAS basically the idea is
that there's three energizers if we can
apply these three things into our work
it'll feel good it'll generate energy
it'll make us more productive and those
three are the first three chapters play
power and people then the second bit of
the book is basically about overcoming
overcoming procrastination and
distraction which are things that loads
of people struggle with where even when
you've made your work energizing we
still have a tendency as humans to
procrastinate from it and so the reason
it's called unblock is because there's
like a few different methods to dealing
with procrastination um in the
productivity literature there's there's
the motivation method which is that oh
you know you just got to be motivated
enough if you're if you're not doing the
thing it's because you're just not
motivated enough you got to want it so
much that like it's so it's so worth it
um and the issue with that obviously is
that motivation waxes and wains it's not
it's not always there all the time then
there's you know a lot of people will
invoke The Narrative of discipline
they're like okay now screw motivation
what you need a discipline and I've I've
definitely made videos about this in the
past before my thinking got a bit more
sophisticated and with discipline it's
like okay cool you know the reason
you're procrastinating is because you
don't have enough discipline or enough
willpower and you should therefore work
on that as a muscle and again I think
discipline has its uses but like living
a life where the the things that matter
to you you're having to discipline
yourself into doing it's just a bit Grim
um it's not a very enjoyable way way to
be and
so the analogy that I sort of came up
with after doing so much research into
productivity into procrastination and
interviewing a bunch of people on this
podcast about procrastination is the
unblock method so the the analogy we
talk about in in the second part is
imagine you have to go to a friend's
house for dinner but for some reason it
feels really painful to walk there like
there's something wrong with your shoes
so the motivation method is like screw
it I'm going to I'm going to battle
through the pain because like I want it
so much that's fine uh the discipline
method is like screw it I'm going to
battle through the pain because I've
made a commitment to be there and I'm a
disciplined person and I don't you know
I don't go back on my word and I will do
the thing the unblock method would be
like hang on why is walking to my
friend's house so painful let me have a
look in my inside my shoe oh there's a
pebble inside my shoe that explains it
let's just remove the pebble and now I
can be on my on my Merry way I love it
and I think that applies to
procrastination so much because
procrastination is fundamentally an
emotional issue there's like three in
particular like major emotional blockers
to procrastination and if we can
recognize them for what they are shine
light on them then it allows us to
remove the remove the pebble so that it
feels less of a grind rather than kind
of having to go through the barriers
using motivational discipline so that's
what the unblock method is well that's
so true isn't it that I guess um a lot
of people look at procrastination with
so much judgment and they judge
themselves for it as if they're getting
something wrong or they're not good
enough and actually when we turn towards
it with a bit of curiosity you pretty
quickly get to see what was causing it
in the first place and what the block is
so that you can like you say get the
stone pull it out and go your Merry way
that's the one amazing and like we're
all so wired to avoid pain and seek out
pleasure but avoid pain more so than
seeking out pleasure yeah and so that's
a big component of why procrastination
is such a pervasive thing because you're
doing you're faced with a task but
there's something about that that feels
aversive or feels painful and until like
a deadline is invoked and until it's
like oh crap like the pain of not doing
the thing is greater than the pain of
doing the thing that's what prompts us
to act but again that's a very stress
stressful way to be yeah and you know if
we can Target procrastination at its
source and figure out what are the
blockers it just again makes life way
easier when we're actually doing the
things that matter to us yeah incredible
and then what's the what's the last um
what did we have we had energize
energize so energize generates energy
make makes you more productive unblock
helps you unblock the things that can
drain your energy and can make work feel
bad that can stop you from
procrastinating and then part three is
sustain so it's like at this point we've
talked about how to have how to add more
joy and Vibes to your work through three
energizers we've talked about how to
beat procrastination by you know using
the three unblockers um at this point
the only thing that's left is to make
sure that our productivity is actually
sustainable over the long term and so
part three is really about burnout and
there's three different types of burnout
as we talk about and the three different
chapters tackle the three different
types of burnout okay yeah because
that's in some ways one of the biggest
um problems isn't it and lots of people
can find a way to you know generate that
that early energy or you know blast
through some procrastination with a a
sort of burst of motivation but when you
ask about whether it can be sustained
most people like it's the it's the New
Year's resolution thing isn't it most of
them are given up by February or
whatever it is exactly so this feels
like a really crucial part of the book I
think so yeah I think making the things
sustainable is such an important part of
productivity I think that's another area
in which the sort of hustle culture
productivity Bros who In fairness I
think are a bit um caricatured um in in
some content out there
but that's less of a thing in that
traditional hustle culture kind of vibe
a whole I'll sleep when I'm dead or like
you know your 20s are for grinding and
then you can always relax later on when
you have kids like L most parents I know
don't relax once they have kids and it
becomes even more of a even more of a
struggle um so yeah I think finding a
way to make our productivity sustainable
um taking appropriate breaks and rest
and recharging and it sounds obvious and
it sounds boring but you know through
the research um you know uncovered a few
like interesting things around how to
recharge effectively that I didn't I
didn't know before writing the book and
I was like oh this is fun I can share
this with with with the readers of the
book today's episode is very kindly
brought to you by hu now I've personally
been using hu regularly since 2017 when
I discovered it in my fifth year of
medical school and if you've not heard
of hu they are business that creates
convenient affordable meals in a variety
of different forms but all of them are
nutritionally complete so they have the
perfect balance of nutrients carbs
fibers protein and fat and contain 26
vitamins and minerals and they've now
packaged some of their most popular
products into their bests seller bundle
so you can try out all the heel products
and see which ones Vibe with you there
is Hu Black Edition which is my personal
favorite because it's really tasty and
it's high protein so 40 g of protein and
all you have to do is add water or milk
and you can shake it up and take it with
you wherever you want to go the bundle
also has heeles instant meals which you
make in the microwave there's heuel
ready to drink range which are pre-made
shakes in a bottle which is super handy
and I've actually grabbed a few of these
in the airport when I've been between
flights while traveling and finally you
also get some of the new heel bars which
I'm very excited to try out myself plus
if you're a new customer you get a
totally free heel t-shirt and a Shaker
and pot with your first order now I
wouldn't recommend having every meal as
heel because that would get a bit much
but it's a fantastic supplement to a
healthy balanced diet so often for me
I'll have heel either for breakfast or
for lunch where the alternative would be
to otherwise have a relatively unhealthy
breakfast and so heal is a great way to
make sure that you at least have the
basics covered when you are living a
hectic and or busy life he has very
kindly been a longtime supporter of the
podcast as well and I actually did an
interview with the founder of hu Julian
Hearn which was a great episode and
that's in season one of the Deep dive
podcast so anyway thank you so much he
for sponsoring this episode this season
is Once Again being sponsored very
kindly by trading 212 now people ask me
all the time for investment advice uh
because they see that I've made money
and I've made videos talking about where
I'm investing that money the thing that
Warren Buffett and basically everyone
who's sensible in the space recommends
which is to invest in Broad stock market
index funds which you can do completely
for free using trading 212 trading 212
is a fantastic app that lets you invest
in stocks and shares and funds in a Comm
free fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone into the platform and has
created a p of Investments having done a
bunch of research and stuff and that P
might be like I don't know 20% Apple 20%
Tesla 10% this 10% that but it generally
way more complicated than that and you
can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with £100 and
you were like okay that P looks good it
will split out that1 based on the
allocations of the P which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your stet then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of100 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode who who is the book for do you
think who who are you sort of hoping to
send out into the world too yeah so we
were trying to figure out this out um
cuz you know when you're writing and
marketing and stuff everyone says you
should figure out your ideal ideal
audience or you know the P the one
person that you're talking to but I
think for a book like this it's not
really that there is one person it's not
like targeted at like I don't know a
17-year-old student or like a
23-year-old entrepreneur or whatever the
thing might be it's just that it's I'm
hoping that anyone who wants to be produ
who wants to be more productive it's
it's it's not it's not really a book for
people who are like who have no goals
and have no desire to have any goals
it's it's for people who are goal
oriented they want to go after certain
things that are meaningful to them
whether it's in work or in health or in
relationships or family or anything like
that a lot of us have these goals and
for people who want to work towards
those goals but in a way that doesn't
require sacrificing their own like
physical and mental health yeah um
essentially yeah like how how people who
want to do more of the things that
matter to them but who want that process
to be enjoyable and meaningful and
sustainable as well yeah so people like
me basically and I hope there are you
know if if the content is anything to go
by I've been sort of sharing this kind
of philosophy for the last few years on
the YouTube channel and people seem to
really Vibe with it so I'm hoping that
people will vibe with the book as well
and and there's you know very few people
that don't want to do more of what
matters most of them and and I guess
with Modern Life as well it pulls us so
many of us away from the things that we
feel matter doesn't it it feels like we
have to spend a lot of our time doing
things that we don't care about just to
be able to you know keep a ro of over
our head or feed families and that kind
of thing and then whatever time we have
left is the stuff we care about um so it
feels like this is a sort of for
everyone book I think so yeah it's if it
feels a bit grandious to say it's for
everyone but like you know we kind of
wrote it with that in mind that we want
anyone to be able to take something away
from this and then like we we worked
quite hard to make sure that the or try
our best to make the examples as wide
ranging as possible cuz get know my
experience is being being a medical
student working as a doctor and being a
YouTuber these are fairly unusual things
in the grand scheme of things like most
people are not doctors and or YouTubers
and or entrepreneurs um but I think the
methods of Feelgood productivity and
kind of the science behind it is
applicable to basically anyone yeah and
so it's not just people who are like who
have control of their own time who are
entrepreneurs who can apply Feelgood
productivity I think it's anyone even if
you have a normal day job that you don't
really like that's kind of really what
the first three chapters are about like
with everything that we do there is a
way to make it feel better yeah and if
we I know I speak to a lot of people who
don't enjoy their jobs but who are
approaching it in a kind of
disempowered you know ah I hate my job
but there's nothing I can do about it
cuz I hate my boss it's like we actually
have a lot more power in these
situations than we think and that's what
basically all of chapter 2 is as well so
what what are the kind of you know are
there some specific strategies for sort
of you know searching for The Joy or the
pleasure in what is otherwise the kind
of job you hate or that kind of thing
yeah absolutely so the first three three
chapters play power and people I think
from from all the work I've done on this
uh those are really the three main
levers that make work feel good so we've
got you know one specific strategy in
play for example is um you know in video
games they've got the concept of side
quests like you've got the main story
line but then you've got these optional
things that you can do on the side yeah
and side quests add a lot of variety to
a game because it lets you explore your
curiosity similarly if you're let's say
you're working in a job that you don't
that you don't enjoy the worst thing you
can do in that context is to sort of
disengage because it's to be like Oh I'm
just I'm going to quite quit I'm just
going to do the bare minimum I just I
just need to get through the day yeah I
just need the clock to hit 5:00 cuz then
I can go home and do what I what I truly
enjoy cuz now you're living like 8 hours
of your day like as a zombie where
you're just clock watching until the end
of the day um approaching that with a
little bit more of a spirit of play like
what can I find in my work to treat as a
bit of a side quest can I explore my
curiosity to this new area I had a
friend who was working as a Psychiatry
trainee who you know as a as a doctor
who was just kind of interested in like
why is the hospitals NHS computer system
so crap and every doctor has that
thought but no one does anything about
it just like well I guess it's just the
NHS but she decided to go to the IT
people and like go into the basement
where they where they dwell and like
talk to them and be like hey what's
going on here and turns out that
actually there's all sorts of
interesting things where like the It
people want to speak to the doctors but
they don't want to disturb them and the
doctors are always busy so they can't
talk to the IT people and so the systems
end up being kind of weirdly designed
and so single-handedly she found a side
quest for herself she found a way to
make her day job which she wasn't really
enjoying at the time feel way more
enjoyable because now she's got this
little project and she's also made the
environment where she works just like
objectively better for her colleagues
and for her patients because now it is
speaking more to the doctors and so this
little things like that where finding a
side quest can help you get more
enjoyment out of even a really really
really crappy job that's that's so good
you know I I feel like I almost might
have done that once in my life where I
um when I was doing my I worked in a
supermarket and it was just almost one
of the most difficult jobs I've done
partly because of just the the monotony
of some of the jobs in the borom and
stuff like that and I remember um in
between on those sort quieter days where
you might have five or 10 minutes
between customers and you would just be
expected to kind of sit there and it was
back in the days when you used to have
when you used to pay by card you would
have a little bit of paper that put
through and pill out of your seat so I'd
get those little bits of paper and I
would like speedrite mini poems or like
little kind of anecdotes and things like
that in between C to see what I could
come up with in before somebody else
walked along kind of thing and um and
those sorts of things made the day
really move along but also I was then
challenging myself and I was quite
enjoying myself in between but just in
whatever little way I could within the
restrictions of that job yeah um but I
guess it's that isn't it it's finding
something little in your day that you
can kind of inject a little bit of Joy
or pleasure or yeah absolutely basically
anyone can do that in basically any job
like even even even amongst Medics yes
there are some days where you it's
literally non-stop but generally those
days are quite fun it's like people tend
to be more disengaged when there's days
where it's kind of quiet it's kind of
boring you're just sort of scrolling on
your phone in those days in particular
if you can find like you know writing
poetry on on the receipts or yeah that
sort of stuff yeah um one of one of the
other strategies we talk about in the
play chapter is uh trying to find sort
of trying to create a challenge for
yourself cuz it's like if you imagine if
you're if you imagine playing I don't
know tennis against a three-year-old
it's not it's it's not going to be
particularly fun because you're just
going to trans them similarly if you
imagine playing tennis against Roger
fedra it's probably not going to be very
fun because he's going to just destroy
you and so there's for for anything to
be enjoyable there's got to be a certain
level of challenge now the challenge
obviously is like if you are working
somewhere where there isn't a challenge
in what you're doing what do you do then
so we've got the story of this guy
called Matthew who is actually an author
who back in the day used to work at
McDonald's and used to work at the
McDonald's drive-through
and he was like you know this is really
boring working like 12 hours a day at
the McDonald's McDonald's drive-through
so the way he created a challenge for
himself was he would try and upsell the
customers on a different sauce every day
so he'd be like you know someone would
be like you know would you like fries
with that they'd be like yeah sure and
then he would be like and would you like
any barbecue sauce with that and they'd
be like no I'm good and he would be like
oh no but like you know it's it's it's
really good like you I'd really
recommend it and they'd be like no you
know I think I'm fine I think I'm fine
with catchup he'd be like really are you
sure cuz the last customer said that and
then they were really happy with the
barbecue sauce and then be like okay
fine I'll take the barbecue it's a bit
of fun the customer is not really
expecting it but it's just kind of
lightens up their day a bit yeah for
Matthew working at the drivethru he's
playing a little game with himself to
see how many barbecue sources he can
upsell his manager is happy because he's
increasing the revenue of the drive-thru
and there there little things little
challenges that you can add to whatever
job you're doing to just make it more
fun by default which makes it feel good
which makes you more productive which
makes you more energized which is good
for everything in life I I really like
that because I think in reality most
people
have a job that they would didn't dream
of or wouldn't choose if they could
choose any job in the world right they
just they're trying to feed the families
and keep a roof over their heads and
this is where they've landed and rather
than that kind of you've got to leave
your job and fill the risk and create a
you know your own company and and all of
these things that in reality
are really far from where most people
are able to to get to um because of
life's limitation
um actually it doesn't mean then you've
got to just endure hardship and and
awfulness if you hate your job you can
you can work on improving what is even
if you have you know Ambitions of of
doing other things that's not the only
way yeah absolutely I think I'm I'm not
a huge fan of the whole like oh find
what you love and then like quit your
job and make a business out of the thing
cuz like as you said it's actually not
attainable for most people right now and
I think
you know I'm I'm all for people quitting
their jobs if they're if they're
fundamentally you know disengaged and
find it meaningless work but there's a
lot we can do before we get to that
point in terms of incorporating power
play people in terms of like finding a
way to make the work feel good there's
so much we can do before we get to a
point of like okay I must quit my job
yeah the the way I think of it is like
if you're considering quitting your job
because you hate it and you have you
know to the best of your ability made a
reasonable effort and made or made a
pretty reasonable effort to make the job
more enjoyable if at that point it's
still miserable then it's probably
worthwhile leaving obviously it's harder
for some people than for others to be
able to do that depending on like
dependence and all this all this stuff
but I think there's so much power that
we have over our own experience of our
work and it's easy to be to feel
disempowered and disengaged just because
our manager sucks or we're not getting
the recognition that we'd like yeah we
have a lot of power in those in those
context it's really nice that it then
can apply to everybody no matter what
your Ambitions or or the circumstances
you're dealing with it's kind of pretty
Universal isn't it that these are kind
kind of strategies that you can use
whatever your
circumstances to improve your
productivity and and be the best that
you can be but also kind of enjoy the
ride yeah a bit better absolutely
because what's the point of being
productive if the ride is miserable
exactly so did you feel like you had you
know well do you even do you call
yourself a teacher these days do you
feel like you're a teacher internally
yeah okay like I don't really think of
myself as a YouTuber or as a writer or
as a whatever entrepreneur I think of
myself more as a teacher cuz that's
always been the thing that's brought me
the most like meaning and joy um I I I I
think it was like 2019 or something I
was sort of like a year into my job as a
doctor and I was feeling a bit like okay
you know I'm not sure this is really
right for me I was I was I was feeling
um what I now know is misalignment
burnout where you're sort of doing a
thing but like and you're doing well at
the thing but you this there's something
a bit off and I feel a bit like uh I'm
not I'm not really sure this is that
fulfilling and so I went on the internet
and read a bunch of books around like
how to figure out what to do with your
life which is a question that we all
struggle with um and one of the
exercises that I came across um is this
uh gravestone technique where you ask
yourself what would I want written on my
gravestone and you extend that to be
like what would I want people to say at
my
funeral um and I realized that the thing
that I want written on my gravestone was
is some combination of good father good
husband and inspirational teacher and
like that was the thing I was like oh
that's the thing and I spent a long time
reflecting about this and realized that
for me the most in the most joy and
meaning that I got out of working in
medicine was when I had a medical
student with me who I could like Teach
as we were going through the patients
seeing stuff and quizzing them on the
drugs and that was just so much fun
whereas doing the day-to-day job
normally there are some doctors who just
love interacting with patients and love
like helping people and saving lives in
that sense for me I enjoyed that bit but
I enjoyed the teaching a lot more and I
realized I'd rather be a medical
educator than a medical practitioner and
that was a big like whoa moment for me
because i' I'd ALS that helped me
realize that actually from the age of 13
onwards I was always doing teaching here
and there always helping students at
school with their exams doing private
tutoring and I really enjoyed that stuff
and so that was a big realization that
helped me realize that actually I don't
think practicing medicine fulltime is
for me I want to be more of a teacher
and find a way to continue to grow and
learn cool stuff myself apply it to my
life and then find a way to share it and
teach it with others and that was really
what the book is and what videos are and
what the podcast is it's like I get to
interview people and learn cool stuff
from them and then share that in in
videos and and through the book and is
that how the idea of putting all the you
know the stuff from the videos into the
book and does it does it filter in stuff
from the videos that you've talked about
before or is it all brand new a lot of
it is brand new annoyingly it's like I
wish there was more from the videos
because it would have been less work but
um initially when I started writing it I
was thinking oh how hard can it be I've
already made like a dozen videos on
productivity if not more like I I can
type really fast I can just bang the
book out in like a month and then I got
about 10,000 words in in terms of like
the stuff I already had had off the top
of my head I was like I've run out of
content like I need to do more research
and then I dove into the research and
that was when like reading the books and
the research papers and stuff that like
all of the dots started to connect yeah
and you know people kept on saying that
like why don't you make videos about
this stuff as you're writing the book
but it was if it felt kind of weird
because the book was like such a an
individual project and different from
the videos I think for future books I
would like videos to be a bit more
overlapping with the content in the book
because it will just reduce the amount
of work but there's a lot of almost
everything in the book is new and I
haven't talked about it in videos before
yeah yeah so it's all fresh and brand
new yeah and does it kind of take so
does it all take um you know this idea
of kind of being a teacher and then
bringing out the book does that give you
an idea of where you want to take things
in the future through like the videos or
yeah yeah I think it just comes down
down to that being like the i' I've
realized that the thing that brings me
the most Joy is learning and growing
myself and then sharing that learning
and growth with other people and I'm
fairly agnostic as to the medium or the
format so YouTube videos a format
Instagram reals as a format like podcast
is a format books are a format and
formats come and go I think books are
around to stay because they've been
around for a long time I don't imagine
that when I'm in when I'm when I'm 55
I'll like be saying hey what's up guys
to a YouTube
but I do like the idea of continuing to
write books continuing to teach people
in real life and I guess we'll just
adapt to platforms as as they come out
yeah yeah yeah and and I want to go back
to the idea of procrastination because I
feel like this is such a huge subject
and everybody struggles with it right I
don't know anyone who well I think if
they say they don't probably lying yeah
um so I wonder if we can go back to the
kind of
the procrastination section of the
book
and we talked a bit earlier about how
procrastination is sort of Often
underlied by sort of fear or other
emotions around the thing that you're
supposed to be doing can you give us a
bit more of an insight into that yeah
sure um so yeah chapters four five and
six were about beating procrastination
chapter 4 is um get clarity because
Clarity is like a big like the first
major hurdle
chapter five is courage which is all
about like the emotions and fear being
the main one and then chap chapter six
is get started so if I just bookend the
the stuff about the emotions initially
we've got Clarity where a lot of people
will be like okay I'm procrastinating
from
exercise and if you think think about
it's like they don't really have any
Clarity on what exercise even means if
someone's a beginner to exercise be like
the there's all sorts of like stuff
where it's
like you know at one point I was I was I
was trying to take up running I was like
cool I'm just going to take up running I
didn't I didn't know what that meant
like how how often am I running like
where am I going do I need any special
kind of shoes like what app do I use on
my phone to track the runs I know people
do that should I wear the Apple there's
basic questions where like a runner
might just be like look man just wear
any shoes and just go out for a run but
as someone who hadn't experienced what
running was as like an exercise activity
I just didn't have Clarity on it which
meant I procrastinated for like a whole
3 months being like Oh at some point
they'll get R to this running thing I
didn't know exactly what it was yeah and
so the first step in in being
procrastination is actually getting
Clarity on why you want to do the thing
what the thing actually is and like when
and where you're going to do the thing
because even just that like even just
committing to a time and a place and
putting the thing in your calendar I
think solves like half of
procrastination within like a few
seconds so it's like I'm going to go to
the gym at some point it's never going
to happen and it's like I'm going to go
to the gym every Monday at 500 p.m. it's
way more likely to happen than than than
the
alternative and so the next thing is
like okay let's say the thing is is now
in your calendar like in in someone's
case it might be I don't know working on
this presentation for example it's like
I've been procrastinating from this
presentation for such a long time at
work and I finally put it in my calendar
I know what I need to do and then it
gets to 300 p.m. on the Monday or
whenever you put put it in the calendar
and then there's something that like
holds you back and you feel there like a
resistance a resistance exactly that
resistance and that resistance is
usually some kind of emotion and the
most common emotion is is fear like fear
tends to be the thing at the root of
procrastination the other one is
self-doubt you can say self-doubt is
sort of a subset of fear because you're
afraid of the thing being judged by
someone else and that's when we have to
I guess you know from your background as
from from your background in therapy a
lot of strategies around uh naming the
emotion uh telling ourselves a different
story about the emotion to reduce the
impact it has on us and fundamentally
acting in the face of that emotion
anyway if we recognize the emotion is
never truly going to go away mhm there's
a there's a fun study where they they
called it the Batman
effect um where they got a bunch of kids
and they got them to do some some sort
of activity some sort of game and then
and so half the kids would they were
just told to do the the activity but the
other half of the kids they were told to
imagine that they were a like superhero
that they vibed with like Batman or Dora
the Explorer or whatever okay and they
found that the group who pretended they
were someone else who acted as if they
were Batman or Dora the Explorer
performed better at the exercise and
felt better as a result of doing it than
the group that had that had no
instructions and so Adele for example
has spoken about how back in the day she
was she had loads of stage fright when
she was first getting her singing career
off the ground and so she would adopt
this Alter Ego you know this woman
called Sasha Carter who was like a
mixture of two different singers and she
would be like okay when I'm on stage I'm
going to be Sasha cter I'm not going to
be Adell I'm going to be this version of
me and that was the thing that allowed
to overcome a stage fright and like do
the thing and so one of yeah this is one
of the strategies in the book trying to
figure out what is that Batman for you
what is that Alter Ego m like for me
when I do public speaking I imagine
myself not as me because I'm like every
all the all the emotions get in the way
I imagine myself as uh young Charles
Xavier from the X-Men series cuz he's
cool it's like an X-Men first Class
series he like cool guy nice accent
goodlooking this is before he goes you
into into the wheelchair um I'm like
cool I'm just imagining myself as young
Charles Xavier and I'm just here to
teach and I'm here to share and I'm
going to have a smile on my face and I'm
going to enjoy it and it means that I
can get over that initial hurdle which
would otherwise stop me from
filming a video or from going on stage
yeah and there's something quite freeing
in that isn't there I remember actually
as a kid um being super shy and kind of
introvert but it really enjoyed doing
theater work and there was something
about the freedom of pretending to be
someone else for a minute and and that
you can kind of be as silly as you like
because it's not you and um yeah so
there I don't know there's something in
that isn't there about this idea of kind
of being able to take on the Persona of
of an ideal or a role model or a an
image of something yeah that just allows
you to kind of Leave Behind the
insecurities when maybe that's when
people are attaching their own kind of
self-worth to something that then
becomes a block that kind of paralyzes
them from making the decision to start
or something yeah I found this with the
book quite a lot like I realized that a
lot of what caused my procrastination
from writing was the fear of like oh
this needs to be good it's like the bar
was too high so you had procrastination
from writing a lot yeah did you as well
when you were oh for sure for sure I've
already talked to you about my uh
tendency to kind of buy animal or look
for animals to buy Extreme Ways to
procrastinate but how did you so so you
Ed the Batman technique for writing uh a
little bit yeah I I I sort of came
across that a little bit later I I was
like damn I wish I'd come across this
sooner um the way I did it for the book
is is sort of just trying to lower the
bar as much as possible okay to
recognize that like okay I feel like I
feel like every word I right needs to be
this good but actually what if it
doesn't what if what if it just needs to
what if it just needs to exist what if
just I just need to get it onto the page
yeah um the aim is not to write a good
book the aim is to write something and
then we'll worry about the good later on
yeah um and when I was I interviewed Cal
Newport who's written a bunch of these
books over the last last couple of
decades and he said the thing he tells
himself he's written like five or six
books at this point the thing he tells
himself for every book is this one just
needs to be reasonable the next one is
going to be good and he's been kind of
sustaining that that momentum by this
one just needs to be reasonable yeah and
I think there's a lot of value in I
think in in the modern world we're told
that like quality matters and like
quality is really important but actually
having a bar for Quality when you're a
beginner at the thing it just holds you
back it's like you know if someone wants
their very first YouTube video or very
first Tik Tok or very first book to be a
masterpiece they're just never going to
do it yeah if you lower the bar it's
like the lower the bar is the easier to
get started yeah and often when it comes
to procrastination getting started is
the hardest part you know the law of
inertia once you start moving it becomes
easier to continue going yeah um and so
really all of these strategies are
around just getting over the hurdle
doing the thing five minutes and then
usually at that point we start to get
into flow yeah yeah and I guess if you
were doing I don't know any kind of you
know if you're learning piano or
Jiu-Jitsu or whatever it is you would
never expect yourself to do the advanced
stuff first right in that first session
it's just do something and it's it's
starting something in motion and
actually in my writing I find that once
I get over that morning emotional roller
coaster of just putting a few words on
the page the rest comes easier it's like
starting isn't it you kind of if you can
just get momentum the momentum can carry
you for a little while yeah whereas if
you're kind of
stuck um it's really hard to just push
into movement yeah absolutely I think
that's that's one of the major
realizations that I've had around
procrastination there like momentum is
so important uh I realized like for for
for filming YouTube videos what I do now
is I I I hit record and I just kind of
start somewhere in I start like 2
minutes in I start recording it's like
oh the first point is blah blah blah
blah blah blah because I just if in in
the past I would I would hit record and
then I'd be overthinking the hook of the
video because the Hook is so important
it's like the first 30 seconds it's like
you know 60% of people might click off
in the first 30 seconds and now again
there's all this pressure on the first
30 seconds which means like oh it's such
a heavy lift to do the first 30 seconds
of a video so now I just start the video
with Point number one which is 30
seconds into the video and then at the
end once I finish the video and I'm like
oh just filmed for half an hour great
now I'm in I've got the momentum now
it's way easier to say hey friends
welcome back to the channel today we're
talking about blah blah blah and to do
the hook okay it's almost like when
you're when you when you're writing
something the introduction is the
hardest part and so a lot of people will
save the introduction for the end
because it's easier to start somewhere
in the middle yeah yeah so you can start
wherever you like and as long as you get
started and what's the amydala hijack oh
amigdala hijack yeah so the igula as as
you would know is the part of the brain
the threat detector part of the brain
obviously there's more Nuance than that
but like to simplify things um and
people who have defects in their
amigdala feel less fear or sometimes
even no fear now fear is a really
valuable emotion because it stops you
from getting run over by a truck when
you're in the middle of the road um and
so people without an amydala just don't
have that sort of fear response but the
amigdala is very responsive to social
threats so back in the day obviously if
there's a line around the corner the
mdas is like firing and you've got the
fight flight response but also back in
the day in our caveman eras uh in our
caveman era sort of being ostracized
from the social group was a real like oh
my God your survival is at stake because
if you get kicked out of the tribe
you're going to get eaten by the lion
and and sort of the amigdala hijack is
kind of what research researchers call
it when um we when our igdal is
overactive in social situations today
that are not like where our survival is
not actually at stake so doing a public
speech like working on a presentation
and delivering that for the first time
any area where we feel like the risk of
judgment or kind of what will other
people think of us will they think me
ridiculous to have the audacity to make
a Tik Tok all that kind of stuff the
amigdala starts to be in in hyperactive
mode which causes the fight or flight
response which causes us to feel very
stressed when we feel stressed it's like
negative feelings we contract we're less
creative we're less productive we're
less energized everything starts to feel
very heavy and so a lot of getting over
procrastination is recognizing that oh
okay the reason I'm finding it so hard
to get started with my book is because
I'm worried about the the Judgment the
threat of judgment from other people
cool this is my brain trying to protect
me this is my migdala trying to protect
me because it's worried I'm going to be
ostracized from the group thank you
brain for giving me the survival signal
but I can choose to ignore that because
actually you know I'm in an environment
where I'm not actually worried about
lions and tigers and stuff so it's still
gets to kind of voice its
um its opinions on stuff but it doesn't
get to sit in the driving seat sort of
thing you're still choosing to go
forward but the yeah the voice of fear
is there exactly yeah that's that's a
nice way of describing the voice of fear
so the MD is basically the voice of fear
and the voice of fear stops so many
people from going after their dreams
because they're afraid of whatever yeah
and recognizing yeah you know the brain
is designed to protect us and but
actually protecting us is generally not
in our best interests when it comes to
achieving our dreams or going after to
the Future that we want this episode is
sponsored by kajabi and they've actually
got something really valuable for all of
our deep dive listeners now if you
haven't heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we been using this product for
the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to a $5,000 package for the
parttime YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
that lifetime kajabi have paid out over6
billion dollar to creators that's
billion with a be and over a thousand
creators have become millionaires
through products on the platform now
back in May 2023 I did a keynote at a
kajabi in real life kajabi Heroes Event
in Austin Texas and in that keynote I
talked about the exact steps that I use
to grow my business from zero to over
$2.5 million per year from course
Revenue alone now people paid for the
pretty expensive tickets to watch this
keynote at the kajabi hero live event
but as an exclusive deal for deep dive
listeners kajabi have very kindly
offered to provide the recording of that
keynote completely for free to anyone
who listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode so world of I mean it's
interesting because you you often talk
about World of Warcraft and your like
your love for the game and stuff in your
content um but it comes up in the book
right and you've kind of managed to
thread it in and make it useful can you
remember where yeah so in the chapter
about play um you talk about talk about
World of Warcraft I try to I try to
shoehorn a reference of I I try to
shoehorn a reference to World of
Warcraft and just cuz it's a bit more
fun um so I I used to be absolutely
addicted to this game um I played for
around like 185 days like non-stop like
in total like 185 time 24 hours across
like a threeyear period that which on
average was about 3 and a half hours per
day between the age of 14 and 17 which
is a lot of time I'm like damn how did I
possibly do play video games three and a
half hours a day um but World of
Warcraft is very addictive because OB
it's like one of the most addictive
games ever made and uh what you do is
like you have a little character like
I'm seph off the Warlock and like you go
and kill things and then you get gear
and then you do quests you kill more
things and you get better ones and robes
and stuff um and one of the things you
know the there's a few interesting
lessons we can take from video game
design to apply to our own productivity
one of them is the power of the
experience bar cuz it's like every time
you do something you feel as if you're
you're gaining some experience points
and then you're leveling up and you get
this like ding it's like it goes all and
and you learn a new skill um and this is
where things like uh tracking a word
count if you're a writer or if you're a
student doing an essay or something is
really helpful because you can literally
see the progress bar and seeing progress
happen is a big part of what gives us
the momentum to continue continue the
thing because otherwise stuff can be
quite boring if you don't see progress
yeah we need to see your progress don't
we yeah and then the other thing as well
is um just the fact that you can play a
different character and we kind of
talked about this in the context of the
Batman effect but it also applies to
play so um there was this I think a
psychologist or psychiatrist many years
ago who um founded the US's uh the the
United States National Institute for
play is like doing research on like play
and how it relates to humans and what we
can learn about ourselves based on how
we play and he did these things called
play histories where he interviewed like
5,000 people from all walks of life like
you know people with normal jobs no
Prize winners Olympic athletes people in
prison he just interviewed loads of
people and he asked them lots of
detailed questions about how they played
when they were younger and he got these
5,000 different play histories and he
came up with this basically like eight
different play personalities eight
different archetypes of what people
enjoyed when they're when they were
playing so like for someone it might be
like the Storyteller this is someone who
really enjoyed telling stories and like
drama and theater and this sort of stuff
uh there's the jester someone who like
really enjoyed pranks and jokes and
stuff there's the director you know
these are the kids who enjoyed
organizing their fellow play their
fellow friends and like organizing a
play and all this stuff there's like
eight different ones of these and one of
the things that we can take away from
this is that a understanding what our
own play personality is and you know
there's some exercises in the book to
figure that out but B if we want to
approach our work more in the spirit of
play we can choose to adopt a different
personality when we're doing stuff so
for example let's say I'm like you know
it's like in World of Warcraft you're
choosing a character so you're kind of
choosing which character you want to
approach the work with so let's say I'm
doing a a presentation at work and I'm
thinking okay this presentation is
really boring but I'm going to adopt the
Storyteller archetype and I'm going to
figure out cool if I were the
Storyteller and you know these are the
characteristics of the Storyteller how
might I incorporate that into my work um
might I try and tell a story might I
figure out like a nice three-part
structure for my PowerPoint might I find
a way to incorporate humor into it which
of questions that if you're not thinking
about it you wouldn't by default think
to incorporate into a boring work
presentation
but a boring work presentation can
become quite fun if you sort of choose a
different character from these eight
play personalities and it's just another
way of it's like we we as adults are
really bad at playing it's like when
we're kids we play all the time and then
we get we get the spirit of play
squashed out of us as we go through
school and exams and Grading and you got
to do well to go to college you got to
go to college to get a good job and it's
like it's it's almost a given that like
partt of growing up is stopping to play
there a nice I think it's a nice quot I
think it's from George beraw which is
that that we we don't stop playing
because we grow old we grow old because
we stop playing and so a lot of this
this first chapter the play chapter is
about helping us as adults realize okay
what are the things that we can actually
incorporate to make our work feel more
playful because it's something that
we're not in the practice of doing and I
really like that idea that you can kind
of take the different personalities and
and choose to adopt one for a day or for
a week or in a certain setting because
you know lots of these sort of different
personality tests and that happen often
in the workplace and stuff and a lot of
people answer saying well I'm like that
some of the time but actually I'm like
that one another set of the time we're
in a different circumstance and and you
kind of realize that you are a bit of
all of them depending on the
circumstance and so you get this sense
of you're not stuck in one you're not
one type of person you can choose to
adopt a different side of yourself or a
different role in a certain situation
that would help you to enjoy it and to
or to find it more fulfilling or to get
the most out of it yeah is it kind of
that yeah absolutely um and so that's
you've got exercises in there you can
kind of choose which or you can work out
which figure out your play personality
figure out which one you want to you
want to go for um so again like the the
objective was just to try and give you
know when I read a book I like to find
actionable stuff from it it's all well
in good reading but it's like I think
reading and learning without any action
is just you know entertainment and so
you know I'm hoping of the 54 different
experiments in the book like people will
find at at least one or two that they
can Vibe with and the reason we're
calling them experiments is that not all
54 are going to work work for everyone
okay they are somewhat context specific
and like some people will find it easier
to apply some than others but um you
know the idea is that there are
experiments in that you try them you
apply them to your work see how it feels
see if it makes a difference if it does
then great you can continue doing that
if not that's okay you can move on to
another one yeah and it's almost like
taking a bit of a scientific approach to
our own productivity but our own
psychology as well figuring out okay you
know I'm a unique individual let let me
figure out what are the strategy that
work for me that help me feel more
positive emotion when it comes to my
work yeah so that I can enjoy the
journey a bit more and I think that's a
a good a good way to be so in your
experience do you have certain favorites
that you use a lot personally yeah I
really Vibe with a lot of the play stuff
like I think for me just just trying my
best to approach work in the spirit of
play yeah is one of the ultimate hacks
for for making it feel more energizing
um thankfully I'm now at a point where
there's very few things that I do that
don't that I don't enjoy and so what it
was play initially when it was when it
came to doing doing the hard stuff these
days it's a lot of the stuff in part
three sustain because you know as you
would know in this sort of content
creator career where you're writing
writing books and doing the videos and
all this kind of stuff there's always
more things you could be doing
especially once you get some level of
success the amount of inbound that comes
your way is just like completely absurd
in like a good way but it also means
that there are like just way too many
opportunities and so it can be easy to
just say yes to everything and then run
the risk of burning out because actually
it's not sustainable so I think a lot
about kind of overexertion burnout and
depletion burnout and misalignment
burnout and how do I make sure that like
this career that I've been lucky enough
to get into is something that I can
sustain for a very long time I'm I'm
aware that we went through the kind of
different types of burnout when you
interviewed me in our episode but do you
want to kind of talk through the three
of those for this one because I think
they're really crucial aren't they
burnouts not just burnout yeah I think
there's like different different types
of burnout um so the way that we split
up in the book is that there's
overexertion burnout which is when you
try and pack too much into one day and
then you get to the end of the day or
like somewhere during the day and you
feel like you just don't have any energy
anymore there's depletion burnout which
is where you've been sort of more over
the over the long term your energy
levels have gotten so so low to the
point that they're basically depleted
and that's a result of not taking enough
breaks and not recharging and then
there's misalignment burnout which is
that thing we talked about earlier where
you're working towards something but it
feels a bit off because it's not quite
in line with your own values and so
again in each of these chapters we
you've got exercises for how to you know
the science backed way to actually
recharge your energy or like how to
figure out what your own values are so
you can be so you can work in alignment
with them um and just as a quick kind of
practical thing for anyone who doesn't
want to read a book um one of the
interesting things about recharging is
that there are things that we do when
we're drained of energy and then there
are things that recharge our energy and
there's generally not much overlap
between the two things so when I feel
drained of energy I would be tempted to
scroll Tik Tok or BR Instagram or scroll
scroll Twitter or X or or whatever
they've renamed it to I would be tempted
to just watch random Youtube videos and
just like lie on the sofa like on my
phone but if I think about when was the
last time I actually felt recharged by
doing that basically never like you know
scrolling Tik Tok tends not to be a
particularly recharging experience
whereas if I make a list of things that
actually recharge my energy it would be
like going for a walk or like doing 10
minutes of stretches following along to
a YouTube video or playing the guitar or
reading a book or something a little a
little bit more creative and I think
what's interesting about that is that if
we think of if we if if if we feel
drained of
energy the things that it takes to
recharge our energy do require a little
bit of effort it's like going for a walk
is not just like sitting on your phone
and scrolling Tik Tok but it's way
better for us if we go for a walk than
if we scroll Tik Tok on our phone and so
I was just doing a lot of research into
that sort of side of things to figure
out what are the science-backed
strategies for yeah recharging our
energy so that we reduce the risk of
burnout so it's not even necessarily
doing what you feel like doing it's
doing what you know will create the
feelings that you want to have in a
minute yes exactly cuz what we feel like
doing is often the easiest thing and
obviously these social media platforms
are designed to me be as addictive as
possible the notifications there it's so
easy to hop on and start watching a Tik
Tok or start watching a video um but
generally if it when it comes to
avoiding burnout you know spending more
time on social media is not the way to
avoid burnout less time on social media
and more time doing things that actually
re recharge your energy tends to be way
better I often talk to people about sort
of the in between moments as well cuz
often it's quite a small thing isn't it
that we have that tendency to especially
in Burnout usually because there's so
much going on and when there is so much
going on you fill every little moment so
if you've got you know 15 minute gap
between meetings you'll probably check
your emails and you haven't got enough
time to respond to any of them so you're
just just adding to your stress by oh
here's another thing for my to do this
rather than if you took 10 of those 15
minutes and stood outside in the
sunshine or you know or or even you know
got into your car reclined the seat and
just kind of closed your eyes for 10
minutes so the outside of the office and
really kind of deep
relaxation that would be totally
different response physiologically than
checking email yeah absolutely um but I
think you know for for some reason it
feels like unproductive to just go for a
walk or just like sit there it feels
productive to check our email but
actually as you said if you're not going
to action it like you're just adding how
how do you do that during the day though
because I guess people probably have
okay it's Ali abdal he's like
productivity superhero about every
minute of the day is filled with
something you know what is it like
really for you do you take breaks do you
you know Practice What You Preach in
that sense and kind of step outside or
yeah one of one of the one of the things
that every every team member who we've
ever had has kind of said was like Oh I
thought Ollie would be way more
productive than he actually is um cuz
they'll see me taking a little breaks in
my breaks it's like in between filming a
video or in between doing something if I
have an extra 7 minutes I won't check my
email I will grab the guitar and stop
playing and singing along and just sort
of walk around the house or around the
office and annoy everyone with my
singing but that to me is enormously
recharging yeah and you know someone on
the team's like wait what like he's just
he's just singing like what the hell's
going on there or like I'll like whack
out the yoga mat and do like five
minutes of stretching and stuff yeah and
then people be like oh it's a bit weird
but then they'll be like huh that makes
sense actually like we've just been
sitting down all day let's like do some
Hip Flex stretches yeah so I do try and
actively incorporate a lot of that stuff
during like into my day yeah do they
join in or do they just sort of watch
you as if sometimes they do I'm often
like guys come on you know do some
stretches like what's he doing they tend
not to join in with the singing cuz they
feel like shy or something but yeah you
can imagine that in the office with
everybody joining in I love it you we've
got a piano in the office you know play
some songs like Amber who's behind us is
incredible at singing but she never gets
involved because I don't
know fear or anxiety or like it's a bit
weird to sing in in the workplace but I
love it I love it I think very
recharging okay so I mean that good to
kind of squash some of those
misconceptions people might hold that
it's just like super productivity all
the time actually you're much more about
sustaining because you you know clearly
have a high level of productivity given
everything that you run and you know
it's a big deal but that you've managed
to really make that sustainable despite
because I guess probably the pressure is
on you more than most to be super
productive right and to kind of live
that but to to put in the sustain
ability stuff must challenge that
sometimes do you feel guilty ever taking
a break honestly not really
like sometimes if it's like uh you know
there's like a book deadline or
something and like Rowan the editor has
been like oh you know can we really get
these changes through then I'll feel a
bit guilty but then I'll think you know
what why am I feeling guilty like it's a
day late who cares if it's a day late
like it's completely meaningless in the
grand scheme of things he would probably
disagree but like I feel like you know
what I'm just going to go for a walk
down High Park and I'll I'll sit in the
cafe and I'll do it then a bit more fun
bit of a change of scenery change of
scenery and adding variety is another
big big thing that can help a lot of
people with with this sort of stuff but
there's also a cool study that there was
this software company a few years ago
like 20 years like 10 20 years ago who
did a study trying to figure out like
the work habits of the most productive
people in the workplace and they sort of
time tracked about like a couple hundred
to couple thousand different employees
and they found that the most productive
ones on average were um every hour 7
minutes was a break so it's like 43
minutes of work to 17 minutes of break
was the most productive worker and the
people who had more work and fewer
breaks were less productive and so I
think that's kind of nice it's like 25%
of the time they're just chilling and so
that I feel like that's a good that's a
good uh a good sort of cadence that's
kind of true isn't it because if you sit
at the desk for a long time you're not
you're not working efficiently
necessarily you're kind of zoning out or
you're but you're just paing on through
because you feel like you need to sit
there and keep going when actually
you're not being that productive anyway
I also know that you kind of
you shifted from the kind of you know
the old school smart goals stuff and
have come up with something new that's
bigger and
better I would't say bigger and better I
think it's a a different approach to
goal setting so one way of setting goals
is to be to be smart about them specific
measurable you know assignable or
achievable depending on which aconic
relevant time bound um smart goals are
all well and good but um in particular
if someone is a begin to a thing or is
struggling with a thing smart goals tend
to be less effective um like for example
if if you get someone who's kind of
going to the gym for the first time and
trying to trying to build muscle them
setting a smart goal of I want to hit x%
body fat by y date as evidenced by my
dexa scan which will show me like that
would be a smart goal because it's very
measurable it's specific it's time bound
but it's actually kind of demotivating
for the person because they're like a
complete beginner and generally if we're
struggling with a thing um
having a more loose skull is a bit
better um and the the acronym that I
that I've come up with for this is nice
skulls n IC okay so n for near term I
for input based C for controllable and E
for energizing so near term input based
controllable and energizing so let's say
I know if we we take writing a book for
example Neo term is what can I do this
week just like within this week I I
don't I'm not worried about the deadline
we going to do this week input based is
what are the inputs um so input based
goals rather than outcome based goals so
so less that I will write 10,000 words
um but more more that I will write for
20 minutes because that's an input
that's controllable it's within my
control I will write for 4 hours a day
generally outside of most people's
control because life gets in the way but
like a small near-term input based goal
that's e energizing based on power
playing people generally gets us over
that hurdle initially and then once you
have a certain level of expertise in a
field and that point setting a smart
goal an ambitious goal a specific goal
Works quite nicely but in the early days
I think again comes down to lowering the
bar and reducing the mental friction
towards doing the thing which generally
comes from choosing a goal that's
entirely within your control being vague
about it even now for me at the gym I
don't really have any smart goals I'm
just like I want to go gym three times a
week going to lift lift sensible weights
with compound lifts and roughly aim for
Progressive overload like lifting more
than I did the last time a bodybuilder
wouldn't be having goals like that cuz
that's just dumb cuz that's just too
basic a bodybuilder would have specific
goals but I'm not a bodybuilder like I'm
just trying to get to a certain level
and no more beyond that so the nice goal
is a way more energizing and effective
way for me to hit the gym than to set a
very specific goal I love that because
it it's so great for the things that are
really overwhelming as well isn't it so
we'll I'll often talk to people about
sort of you know I don't know the idea
of like climbing a mountain that if you
look up at the you know what would be
the outcome that peak of the mountain
where you want to get it's going to feel
over like an overwhelming amount of work
and you're going to question your
ability to do it so I would often ask
people to sort draw their Horizons in
kind of like that near like just focus
on this week or today um and then rather
than like you say the outcome at the top
is reward yourself for the effort put in
and that input so yeah I love that kind
of input based stuff and often when
we're talking with like um students and
stuff about you know exams and exam
results and that you get so much more
out of school and University and the
education system from learning about
what you're willing to put into
something and your sort of input so if
you you know you reward yourself or you
you get a sense of
um I don't know your sense of self from
how much you're willing to put into
something and the effort that you've put
in regardless of what that final outcome
or result was even though that that's
important because it kind of helps you
to get through certain doors but you
know if you are willing to really give
your all then it's you you've got that
and you you've got evidence of how hard
you're willing to work towards something
yeah absolutely like um in in the early
days of my YouTube channel as well
people would often ask me like oh how
did how did you say stay consistent when
you weren't getting any views and stuff
it's like you know took me like 6 months
and 52 videos to get my first thousand
subscribers um while I was kind of
making two videos a week while doing
medical school and you know the thing I
like at even at the time I realized that
I cannot set a goal for this because if
I set a goal I'm going to be
disappointed it's just it's bit
pointless so I so so my only goal was
I'm just going to make one one or two
videos a week at least one at least one
video a week and that's in it's an input
it's like make videos control it's in my
control it's energizing because making
videos was fun find a way to make it fun
it's a very near- term it's not aiming
for a subscriber count it's not aiming
for views or Revenue
yeah and so even now with my YouTube
channel I try very hard to not set
outcom metric goals that are outside of
my control try and focus on you know
just want to show up and make a video
sharing something that I think is
interesting that could help at least one
person the bar is low that means I've
been able to make a video one one one or
two times a week for the last six years
without really stopping cu the bar is so
low and the channel grows when the bar
is low whereas if the bar is higher I
have a lot of friends who are like I
have to hit a million views for this
upload otherwise the sponsors will pull
out or otherwise it's not worth it and
they they're the ones that burn out
because it's really hard to yeah Peg
yourself to an outcome that is actually
fundamentally outside of your control
and you say the bar is low but actually
you know you were working as a doctor at
the time as well weren't you so how did
you make it fun given that You' probably
done a I don't know 12-h hour shift
beforehand and you know could have just
you know watched Netflix and gone to bed
how did you make it fun enough to get
yourself to do that yeah that was a that
was a big challenge um I really used to
I I found a way to make editing videos
really enjoyable and a lot of the
principles are the one the ones in the
book finding a way to add variety to it
finding a way to kind of level up my
skills each time and make sure that each
video had something that was slightly
different than the previous one and that
meant that when I would get home from
work I would actually prefer to edit a
video for 2 hours than watch Netflix for
2 hours because editing a video was
quite energizing I'd get up from the
desk feeling like yeah I feel like I've
done something good here um there's an
acronym an acronym I talk about in one
of the the final chapters called calm c
a l m yeah which is like the sorts of
activities that recharge our energy so C
for competence a for autonomy L for
Liberty and M for Mellow a bit of a
shoehorn acronym because it was based on
the study but the study had like a
boring acronym I was like how do I the
sour this to make it interesting and
calm activities are the ones that tend
to recharge our energy so competence
where we feel as if we are getting
better at doing the thing autonomy where
we feel like we have we have control
Liberty I.E it's like we it's sort of
detached from the thing that we are
doing for work generally and mellow is
like the stakes are the stakes are low
it's pretty chill like there's no like
deadline those are the things that tend
to feel creatively recharging okay and
so for me coming home and editing videos
I felt competent because I was getting
better I had autonomy cuz I could do
what I wanted it felt creative it was
sort of very different to my day job
working as a doctor editing videos that
it felt like a good distinction and it
was mellow in that I would I would have
some like relaxing music in the
background I'd be fairly chill about it
and that meant that actually I preferred
editing videos to watching Netflix and
that's a great place to be if you're
trying to grow a YouTube channel but if
I if I hated editing videos and it was a
real struggle every time then it would
have been really hard to keep that
consist consistency up yeah because if
stuff doesn't feel good it feels like
you're going up hill and rolling a
border up the hill and again that takes
a lot of discipline a lot of willpower I
don't have a lot of discipline and a lot
of willpower but I've managed to make
videos every week for six years because
I found a way to make it feel good
you've heard that people you didn't you
you don't have willpower but you managed
to make a video a week for six years
yeah feel good thing yeah and tell me
about this is it the write off principle
what's that is that the right way to say
it yeah oh this is just a another thing
I was having fun with um I kind of
realized you know at one point I would I
would get home from work and I'd be I
I'd think okay cool I should I should I
should edit the video because it's
enjoyable and stuff but there would be
some days where I would just flop on the
sofa and I'd say to my housemate I'd say
Molly like I should probably edit a
video right now but I don't don't feel I
have the energy and you are human yeah
yeah there there were a few days where
that happened and sometimes Molly would
be like Ali why don't you just write uh
write the rest of the day off and I was
like okay I could have a write off day
like write off and then I was like huh
sounds more interesting if it sounds
like a German philosopher or something
so I I just I just sent like an email to
my to my email list spelling it re e i t
f f like the wrof principal and I kind
of sent the email as a bit of a joke it
it took me like 10 minutes to write but
loads of people replied being like Oh my
God this is actually really helpful like
when we name something yeah uh
especially if you name it something
that's kind of funny that sounds kind of
legit if you don't know the back story
it just makes it feel better it's like
okay okay cool it's the right off
principal it's it's a write off day
today it's like I think rather than I'm
just being lazy it's like I'm actively
choosing to to write the day off so yeah
to put choice to some so it's okay to
have the you know it's not the no days
off kind of principle it's the it's okay
to respond to your needs and write it
off occationally but you're actively
choosing that and making an informed
choice about yeah like I find there are
some weekends these days where I'm like
oh you know I only filmed two videos
this week I guess I could I guess I
should film a video on Saturday it's
like not really feeling it and then I'll
spend the whole day just sort of in this
stuper where I'm like feeling guilty cuz
I quote should be filming this video and
if I had just written the day off be
like no today's an active day of rest
great now the choice is removed from me
now I don't need to worry that like I
haven't done the thing that I was
supposed to do and I can actually enjoy
myself and do things that are recharging
whereas when I'm in that mode where it's
like I kind of feel guilty about not
doing the thing even though I should be
doing the thing I'll end up scrolling
Tik Tok which is not which is isn't
really a good use of anyone's time and
so you kind of distract yourself without
realizing it and then don't do it anyway
are there days though when you you have
to sort of push through and you have to
just get it done when you don't feel
like it how do you do
that I try and avoid those days at all
costs I I I try and avoid getting to a
situation where that where that happens
um it does it does happen especially
with book deadlines especially with
sponsor like whenever there's an
external deadline that has some level of
kind of pressure to it then I think okay
cool I need to like for example like
proof reading the book it was like okay
I need I need to get this done by like
tomorrow morning I don't have the option
therefore given that I know I have to
get it
done can I just can I find a way to make
it feel good anyway yeah and so in that
context like last week I was I was proof
reading the physical kind of manuscript
of the book I was like you know what it
would be more fun if I just went to a
coffee shop so I went and just packed my
bag went to a coffee shop put my
headphones in went for a little walk
around H Park went to the cafe at the
bottom of H High Park and I just was
proof reading the book there H just more
fun it was like okay finding a way to
make it feel good within the context of
having to do the thing okay I don't like
having to do things but like you know we
we all have to do things we don't like
sometimes so doing the thing that you
don't necessarily want to do but adding
in little moments of Joy or little
things that can just improve the moment
yeah so that it's easier to get through
yeah and I found that like a self
soothing self soothing exactly Al so
when I was working in um in in medicine
I would take a little Bluetooth speaker
in my bag at all times and when I'd be
in the doctor's office on my own writing
discharge letters for hours at a time I
would just attach the Bluetooth speaker
to like the ceiling like or something
and I just play some like Harry Potter
or parts of the Caribbean in the
background and it just made it so much
more fun it's just amazing how much
extra Joy you can get by just having
like an Epic movie soundtrack in the
background while writing discharge
letters um so there's little strategies
like that to just make the thing that I
had to do just feel better yeah made me
more productive more energized more
creative less stressed life was good and
I actually enjoyed working as a doctor
unlike a lot of people that I and so
what would you say to people that you
know you said about the sort of um the
quote about sort of you know getting to
adulthood and I can't remember what the
exact words now but you know losing
losing that sense of play or I think
it's not unusual for adults to
especially adults with lots of
responsibilities to almost lose that
sense of what is it I enjoy I do
everything for everybody else and you
know working and doing the thing you
know for my
boss what do I enjoy how how do we kind
of reenter ourselves with that and and
pull in and work out what we love the
most or what's going to bring pleasure
that is a very good question that I
actually don't have the answer to
um what do you think like you're I guess
you talked to I guess I guess something
that you already do isn't it is you try
lots of stuff like you're not afraid to
go do you know what I'm going to try
sing a lessons or I'm going to learn a
guitar or I'm going to try and you know
do this weights thing in the gym or I'm
going to yeah I guess I can speak to
what what works for me like I I find it
hard to
one of the challenges with with with
writing this book is that a lot of
people who read it will be parents and
I'm not a parent so I don't really know
what it's like to have kids and so I'm
I'm mindful that I don't want to come
across as like you know a productivity
bro being like hey parents this is how
you can figure out how to find joy in
your life so it's like I I can share the
things that that work for me and it is
as you said like I think everyone
has everyone has things that it would be
cool to do so like at the start of the
year or like you know I I I do a sort of
mini quarterly review every three months
um where I'm just like what would be
interesting to try what would be cool to
do um oh you know I've always wanted to
do kite surfing let's add that to the
list so I I keep like a a bucket list of
of things that I'm interested in trying
and so on that list was uh singing
lessons uh recording an album of
original songs learning how to write
music uh glamping learning how to surf
it's like you know doing Acro yoga which
is like acrobatic version of yoga even
though I suck at both all of these
things are on the bucket list and so I
will often I often like when when I'm
doing these reviews and figuring out huh
let me actually just like realign on
what do I actually want to do I look
through the bucket list and be like oh
yeah I guess I guess I could try ACA
yoga like let me see if there's any ACA
yoga classes around and I'll find a time
that works and and make it happen um and
so I think it
is from from what I've heard it's it's
it is too easy to get into that mode of
just being service service service all
the
time and you know one one concept I've
been thinking about recent recently is
like the difference between happiness
and meaning and often people say that
meaning comes from service like like
being being a parent I've heard feels
very meaningful and because you're like
in service to your children even though
according to the studies you get a dip
in your day-to-day levels of happiness
because life is more stressful and
there's more stuff to do and you have
less spare time um but then the
happiness component tends to be when we
have filled our own buckets first so
health wealth love growth Joy those
sorts of things and so those are the the
five sort of buckets I think for myself
health wealth love growth Joy like
and just in my head I'll just like do a
little a a mini audit of like okay how
do I feel my life is out 0 to 10 in each
of these five categories um where 10 is
it couldn't possibly be any better and
zero is it couldn't possibly be any
worse um and I was doing this last night
when I was lying in bed like unable to
sleep and I realized that the joy
category actually is about three out of
10 and I realized that in the
publication with this book and all this
kind of stuff I I had forgotten to take
the time to really think huh am I doing
something that's just purely for for the
joy of doing it that doesn't have
economic output attached to it that's
not in service to someone else and I
realized I actually haven't done that in
a while haven't played any video games
in a while I haven't just like dabbled
with playing the guitar for a while
because it's like I've always had things
to do so that the fact that I recognize
this means that I can kind of rebalance
and one thing I'm actively thinking
about this week is how could I
incorporate a little bit more joy into
what I'm
doing uh so that it's not just work and
it's not just kind of dinner with family
dinner with like it's stuff that I'm
just doing for for my own sake yeah so
find that to be quite it's interesting
cuz I think being a parent I think this
really does resonate actually that
um that when I think the thing with
parents is you feel like you have no
control over your time because you have
very little control over your time
because you have to be present and so
you can't sort of just you know pop out
and join a club or that kind of thing
and so you kind of feel restricted in
that sense but something I noticed
recently myself actually is is often you
feel as a parent that you're
always um there's so many practical
duties that you can get really wrapped
up in those and so you know you got to
get them places and get them dressed and
you know pick them up and do these
things and move them to the next thing
and so you're constantly doing doing
doing and and focusing on that and just
re I mean I was telling you earlier just
recently I um my daughter and I went on
a like a a mommy daughter date where it
was just us we left all the boys at home
and we just went out to the cinema
together and had some dinner and and it
was the first time in probably too way
too long that I've actually stopped to
just enjoy my time with one of my
children I mean I got three children so
it's always chaos right it's just always
someone's trying to speak someone needs
something someone's on the low you know
it's and and so it felt really quite
poignant to just stop and like you say
do something just because we might enjoy
it and that we might connect and have
that time together and that really got
me thinking as you were kind of talking
about play and injecting it into
different experiences that you know how
can I find this in all of the moments
when I'm supposed to be doing all the
mom stuff you know like I you know
getting them all in their car and you
know and and you I think because life is
fast we forget that you know different
things can be a little game or it can be
a more joyful moment than it is you
don't have to just get it done you could
find a way to sort of enjoy the process
a little bit more and um we sometimes do
this game with my son where instead of
like battle him to get dressed um we do
a game where you I kind of like throw
each item of clothing at him and then he
has to like get it on really quickly and
then I throw the next one it gets the
and it's so much more fun when I
actually make the you know time to do it
and take that those extra few moments
that it takes we both smile we both
giggle a little bit and for that you
know five or 10 minutes we've enjoyed
ourselves so much more than we would
have done so it felt less of a chore and
it felt a little bit more like quality
time even though it just had to get done
um so I think you know I think these
prints do apply to it's not as if we're
kind of it's completely separate and
doesn't I think it does apply it's just
more tricky you have to kind of think of
it in in a slightly different way don't
you that we might have less control over
our time because there are dependence
there you can't just sort go off but it
doesn't mean you can't find ways to
inject and and you know you've only got
to give kids half a chance and they'll
find a way to inject fun into something
anyway I mean you got your the S balls
of creativity there ready to go right so
um often the things that they'll find
fun are the the rules that you have to
crack down no we're not going to throw
our food across the kitchen or something
like that but um there's potential there
isn't there to really improve all of
that yeah that's a really nice way of
thinking about it like I think in a lot
of work there's there's things that we
have to do but actually by by taking a
little just a little bit more effort to
do it in a more fun way the returns of
that are like way greater than the
energy that was put into it so like you
throwing the clothes to the kid across
the room probably requires a little bit
more effort energy than you would have
done by default but it does make it feel
more energizing enjoyable and fun and
you probably leave that situation more
recharged than if you had just if it had
been a battle to try and get him to put
the clothes on yeah and again it's sort
of making that choice about not what I
feel like doing now cuz you know first
thing in the morning do you feel like
starting game not really you know but
but actually afterwards you get the
Improvement and how you feel from it so
you feel a bit happier and you're
smiling and you're a bit more energized
yeah yeah yeah I think this applies
applies a lot to work in well actually
any any area of life as well like you
know doing the dishes doing the laundry
even just like thinking like I I I do
find myself thinking whenever I'm doing
something that I feel like uh I think no
like just a millisecond to think how can
I make this fun yeah and it might just
be something really simple like skipping
with a laundry basket to the kitchen
while whistling just something basic
like that and it's like just makes it
more fun it's like now it turns it into
a bit more of a joy than a chore yeah
yeah your favorite music while you're
doing a boring job yeah yeah can really
kind of just shift a moment but it's in
quite a significant way you know you've
only got to put on if you choose your
music carefully that you know lifts your
mood for example that can be a really
distinct shift in your mood State can't
or your emotion state if you um choose
your music carefully and um and then it
bleeds into it bleeds into everything
else that you do for the next like few
hours that I I find anyway like if I
wake up in the morning like oh I've got
to get the clothes out of the dryers
like got to fall them then it's like
I'll start work with more of a sense of
heaviness yeah whereas if I wake up in
the morning I'm like oh I've got clothes
in the dryer cool let me put put the
airpods in let me listen to a podcast
while I'm doing it let me listen to yeah
let me sing a song while doing it so
wake up my house mate and all this stuff
then when I sit down to work I'm like
I'm just automatically in a more
creative mood yeah and it's just these
little tweaks that we can make
throughout our day that help and imagine
then if you've if you've made that sort
of emotional shift for yourself by
injecting a bit of joy and pleasure you
then probably you know when a colleague
walks into the room or when your partner
comes home you probably respond better
to them right and then they probably
respond better back to you and you've
got this like Ricochet of just sort of
little bits of Joy sparking yeah across
the place and sort of the there are also
good ways to fake this you know or or to
to systemize this almost so one of our
team members Tinton told me a really
good strategy which is that that he
realized that if you just set a rule for
yourself that every time you greet
someone you're going to do it with
warmth and effusiveness okay and it's
just like a rule so it's like I found
myself like that day when he told me you
know the two team members would come to
the house and I'd be like I'd open the
door and be like Angus it's so good to
see you how's it going which is just
like you know my default would be like
oh hey man just a bit like more chill
more boring but you know just being
actively effusive in that moment lift my
mood lift their mood everyone loves it
when you greet them with like an
effusive greeting and it just makes
everyone's life that little bit better
yeah um for literally zero cost and so
finding those sorts of moments um yeah
enthusiasm kind of bounces back to you
doesn't it when you offer it out to
people that um gives them permission to
brighten brighten up their response back
to you and um often people are a bit
kind of shy with each other aren't they
and very sort of cold and then as soon
as someone opens up it makes other
people feel less vulnerable to do the
same so everybody becomes a little bit
more bouncy a little bit more chice yeah
I found this used to happen when I was
were when when I was working in the day
job in that whenever I'd walk past the
nurses office I would poke my head in
and be like i' I'd offer them a cup of
tea and I just be like hey anyone fancy
a cup of tea and initially people like
oh it's all right you know they' be
polite about it and be like no you know
are you sure I'm going to make I'm going
to make one for myself it's not that
much more effort like you know I make a
really good cup of tea kind of like the
whole upselling the barbecue sauce and
they be like all right then why not then
it sort of became this thing where it
would just add a little bit of joy to
everyone's day i' I'd have a gap between
patience I'd be like make myself a cup
of tea make one for the nurses I knew
how the different ones the different
nurses took their tea sometimes I would
just make a cup of tea with without the
masking if I saw that like Julie was she
was one one of our head nurses uh Julie
was like deep in paperwork I'd be like
I'm just going to make Julie a cup of
tea and I'd make the cup of tea secretly
be like Julie this is for you and she
would be like oh Ali you're so wonderful
and it was just like it's made her day
it's made mine we all feel good and it
all it cost was you know me spending 10
seconds extra making her a cup of tea
yeah and that's where I think sometimes
with this stuff um often we're looking
for something that's really complex that
we have to pay for that that requires
discipline and and you must be you know
jocker or someone to make it work and it
it really isn't it's lots of these like
little micro moments isn't it that CU I
bet that didn't only improve the moment
between you and Julie but it probably
each time sort of cumulatively improved
your relationship as well it builds up a
connection and and those kind of and and
the better connections you have in your
job probably the better you feel when
you get there cuz you're surrounded in
people you trust and uh enjoy being with
then it's but it has to kind of snowall
doesn't it have to start really small
and then build up so something that
could feel insignificant why bother
actually it doesn't stop there it will
keep going yeah yeah one of the during
during the co lockdown the our Hospital
C cafeteria was doing a special thing
where they were selling scones for like
20p um they would bake loads of scones
sell for 20p so there were about like
six nurses on the ward um any given time
and so when I'd go to lunch I would
bring back six scones and it would it
would cost 1 P2 but it was a such a high
Roi because for that2 I've treated
everyone to scones they're like oh my
God it's like they know it wasn't free
so they know I paid for them they also
know it's 20p but it's just the gesture
of the fact that I thought buy sces for
the for the nurses and they they feel
happy I'd feel happy it's like you know
one of the things we talk about in
chapter 3 which is about people is the
helpers high that you get when you feel
as if you've helped someone even if it's
in a really small way the help as high
makes them feel good makes you feel good
makes everything feel more energized
enjoyable and that's another corol part
of you know the feelg good productivity
philosophy
incredible is there anything else you
want me to no I think that's a good
place to ear things awesome yeah thank
you all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye